Take a look at the room around you and ask yourself a simple question.
What do you think is the most complex system that stores the most information?
Maybe there's a computer in the room.
Maybe there's a tablet. Maybe you're streaming this on your cell phone.
Are those the most complex systems that store vast amounts of information?
You know, the answer to that is clearly no.
The most complex system in the room is you.
In fact, to be specific, it's your DNA.
DNA stores information, much of the information that makes you,
you. In fact, DNA has greater storage capacity than any
technology humans have ever created.
Take for example, just one gram of DNA.
It has roughly the storage capacity of half a million movies.
Now that blows your smartphone away.
Your
body is made up of around one hundred trillion cells.
The DNA in one cell in your body, just one cell if they were unwound, would be about
nine feet in length. That means all the DNA in your body strung together would go
from here to the Sun and back about 70 times.
This raises a very troubling and difficult question both for naturalism and for
pantheism. What can best explain the source of this vast amount of information?
What worldview
best explains the origin of DNA?
To explain the rise of information that we see in nature, some naturalists have
devised a test simply called the monkeys typing Shakespeare theorem.
And the idea is if you have a bunch of monkeys and enough computers and enough time.
Eventually, one of the monkeys will sit down, through a purely blind lucky process,
and type out all the works of Shakespeare.
The idea is to try to explain the rise of information in nature, and in
DNA specifically, through a purely blind process.
In my book Understanding Intelligent Design, my co-author William Dembski and I
cited a quantum computational physicist by the name of Seth Lloyd.
What Seth Lloyd did is mathematically compute exactly how much information could
arise by chance given all the resources of the universe.
What did he conclude? Well, he concluded that chance alone, again with all the
resources of the universe, could not produce all the works of Shakespeare, couldn't
produce one work of Shakespeare, not a chapter, not a page, not a paragraph.
All the resources of the universe, by chance, at best could produce four lines
from one work of Shakespeare. To be or not to be, that is the question, whether it
is nobler in the mind to suffer.
Some time ago, some students and a professor decided to actually
test the monkeys typing Shakespeare theorem.
So they took some monkeys, put them in a zoo with some old computers and typewriters
to see if one of the monkeys would sit down and type out Romeo and Juliet or Hamlet.
Well, what happened? First monkey picked up a rock, climbed up on the computer and
tried to bash it. Some other monkeys climbed up on top and actually went to the
bathroom on the computer. But before you discount this experiment, you know what
happened?
Actually, in the time that they were in there, these monkeys produced roughly six
pages of written text. A string of A's, L's, M's,
J's and an occasional S. Not a single word.
In reality, whenever we come across information and can trace it back to its causal
source, we always find a mind. In fact, imagine you come visit me in Southern
California and we go walking on the beach.
And we walk along. And all of a sudden we stop because we see engraved in the sand a
heart that says, Sean loves Stephanie.
Stephanie is my wife. Now, I know none of you would stop and go, well, that's crazy.
I've heard about earthquakes in Southern California.
But I had no idea when the ground shook, messages arose from the deep.
None of you would stop and try to explain that message by tides or the water
or the wind in some fashion. You would know that the only plausible explanation for
those markings is an intelligent mind.
We know this. In our daily lives, whenever we see information at its source, we
find a mind. For example, you get a text and it's legible.
Trace it back to a texter. Look at the information in a book.
Trace it back to an author. Read a blog and you trace it back to a blogger.
If you go outside and the clouds say, drink Coke, none of you think, oh my goodness,
a storm is coming from the east.
Rather, you would know that that information was put there by an intelligent mind,
in this case, by a pilot. We find more information in DNA than in
anything humans can invent. That's why the best explanation for DNA we see in
nature and in the human body in particular is that it comes from an intelligent
designer, an author of life.